so bringing you some breaking news we
have heard in the last few moments Boris
Johnson will not stand for the Tory
leadership saying that despite having
the support of the MPS required to run
you remember he needs the support of at
least 100 MPS Boris Johnson had come to
the conclusion this would simply not be
the right thing to do as you can't
govern effectively unless you have a
United party in Parliament so breaking
news in the last few moments Boris
Johnson former prime minister will not
be standing for the toy leadership he
says that he did have the support of 100
MPS you remember you need 100 MPS to get
on the ballot for the leadership so
despite having that support the number
of MPS needed to run he's come to the
conclusion and this is a quote from
Boris Johnson this would simply not be
the right thing to do as you can't
govern effectively unless you have a
United party in Parliament
well we can go to Liz Bates now in
Westminster a lot of speculation Liz
about whether or not Boris Johnson would
have the numbers and about whether or
not he would run now we have an answer
we do this is a question that we've been
asking over and over again uh for the
last couple of days finally we know the
answer to it Boris Johnson is not going
to run in this leadership contest this
is quite an extraordinary uh bit of news
this evening if there's one thing that
we can have come to rely on when it
comes to Bryce Johnson he can certainly
provide a lot of political drama and he
has certainly done that in this latest
conservative leadership race if you
remember this has all happened extremely
quickly he flew back from his holiday uh
on Saturday he was on holiday in the
Caribbean with his wife and his children
he came back into London he very quickly
cobbled together a campaign team he
released a couple of pictures of him
calling colleagues he's had a lot of big
name backers Rowan behind him all the
time of course clearly Rishi sunak has
been running away with the campaign when
it comes to nominations from
conservative MPS and he uh in the end
declared
here's candidacy this morning Boris
Johnson never officially entered this
campaign but he has been and make no
doubt about it he has been running a
campaign to re-enter number 10. one of
The Oddities of this campaign though has
been that his allies and people that
were working on that uh campaign team
with him have been briefing journalists
and saying publicly that he had the
numbers to get onto the ballot tomorrow
now if that was true that would have
meant that the competition was
essentially
um sewn up for him because that would
mean that the next stage of it is the
party membership we know he's a big he
was a big favor a big favorite with
conservative uh party members I think
there's now a question mark over whether
that claim that he had those uh 100
um backers in the conservative party was
ever true because at this very late
stage he has uh pulled out of this
contest and um I think it's fair to say
that given
um the the numbers as they stand this
very much leaves the path open now for
uh Rishi sunak to take over in number 10
he's the one with the put with the
support
um among conservative MPS he has way
over the threshold of 100 that is needed
the question now and I think this will
be interesting over the next few hours
over tonight uh into tomorrow morning
where do Boris Johnson's supporters go
because he may not have had a hundred in
the end but he certainly had in public
at 60 there will have been more backers
for Boris Johnson in private who will
they support could Penny Morden now get
to that uh 100 threshold she's still a
candidate in this race if she does and
she ends up on the ballot with Rishi
sunac then that then the pair of them
will be voted on by the conservative
party membership
um I don't think either of them are a
clear favorite looking at the latest
polls so that would be an interesting
contest but as I say absolutely at No
Lack of political drama once again from
Boris Johnson
it really would have been the comeback
of all comebacks uh Liz we have had some
more from the former prime minister
Boris Johnson uh saying in a statement I
believe I am well placed to deliver a
conservative victory in 2024 and tonight
I can confirm that I have cleared the
very high hurdle of 102 nominations
including a proposer and a seconder and
I could put my nomination in tomorrow he
says he goes on to say there is a very
good chance that I would be successful
in the election with conservative party
members and that I could indeed be back
in Downing Street on Friday but in the
course of the last days I've sadly come
to the conclusion that this would simply
not be the right thing to do you can't
govern effectively unless you have a
United party in Parliament he also said
that due to the failure to reach a deal
with Rishi sunak and Penny mordant I'm
afraid the best thing is that I do not
allow my nomination to go for forward
and commit my support to whoever
succeeds I believe I have much to offer
but I'm afraid that this is simply not
the right time the former prime minister
has said in